y con
irán está listo para dialogar sobre el
acuerdo nuclear pero no bajo la presión
de occidente
ese fue el mensaje que el presidente
iraní ebrahim raisi comunicó a través de
la televisión estatal el sábado no
tenemos miedo al diálogo y las
negociaciones en absoluto lo que estamos
buscando en estas conversaciones es el
retiro de las sanciones injustas el tema
central de estas charlas serán los
intereses de la gran nación iraní y las
discusiones para relanzar el acuerdo
nuclear de 2015 se reanudaron en abril
en viena con el apoyo de la unión
europea
pero esos diálogos se han estancado
desde que rise y también objeto de
sanciones de eeuu fue electo el 18 de
junio y su gobierno parece estar feliz
con el lento avance de las negociaciones
porque la otra parte sabe muy bien que
un proceso de dos o tres meses es
necesario para que el nuevo gobierno se
instale y tome cualquier decisión
desde su llegada a la casa blanca el
presidente estadounidense joe biden ha
presionado para el regreso al diálogo
aunque ha mantenido las sanciones
impuestas por su antecesor donald trump
y hasta que las partes se pongan de
acuerdo nadie parece dispuesto a ceder
el viernes pasado cuatro agentes de la
inteligencia iraní fueron incluidos en
la lista negra
washington nos acusa de planear el
secuestro de la periodista
estadounidense iraní massy ar y medial
acusaciones que teherán rechaza